e
e e
open up the public hearing and hear from
the prime sponsor representative Cole
good morning representative Cole good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
Commerce
Committee HB 733 FN all right this is
new legislation we haven't seen it
before up here at the State House this
is something that's uh going across the
states here in the US so let's get into
it what is tlf or thirdparty litigation
financing it is when an investor helps
finance a lawsuit in which the investor
has no personal stake
at the moment parties involved in tplf
Agreements are not required to disclose
these
actions so defendants and courts do not
know the presence or identity of the
funders as real parties with financial
interest in the
case lenders who engage in tlf are
largely unregulated and as a result tplf
attracts hedge funds to participate in
litigation financers because the
industry is not subject to the same
limitations and Regulatory oversight as
normal consumer
loans this avoids critical consumer
protection oversights which is why the
bill landed in this committee it also
attracts outside financers such as
foreign entities influencing lawsuits do
you want to take a the look at the law
on page number
three or the bill I should
say I want to point out lines 9 through
28 and that's dealing with the foreign
entities I know represent spear had a
question about the governor and that's
where it's it that's where it lands in
this bill that's just part of the
definition yep since you're looking
right at
me I know what it is and we're not
taking questions oh okay let him finish
this stop looking at
me all
right litigation abuse is notable factor
causing an upward pressure on insurance
costs and it's only getting worse across
the country and right here in New
Hampshire this is known as a tort tax
okay I'm sure someone behind me can
explain a Tor tax much better than I can
they could be more eloquent about it but
it's basically causing upward pressures
of 15 to
20% in the
lawsuits one way the states have begun
to combat such abuse is through the TPL
of transparency laws I've attached a
list of these states to the packet that
I handed out to you that have already
passed laws or the court rules and it's
part of my testimony so working with
Miss NATO and Mr leine we decided base
our legislation on the en coil model
that was released late last year so
that's what this this whole bill is
modeled after tplf is estimated to be a
400 billion billion with a B Global
industry it's essentially turning our
Civil Justice System into another
commodity for investors to make
exorbitant
profits to ensure a high rate of return
on its investment the fun seeks to
increase the likelihood of a trust trial
thus enhancing the possibility of
frivolous and misguided legislation or
litigation I'm Sorry by turning the
Civil Justice System into a money-making
machine tplf discourages amicable
settlements of disputes and instead
encourages aggressive and prolonged
litigation of marginal or frivolous
claims this again adds to the state's
already significant tort tax on
households it drives up the cost of
products services and
Insurance states have started to en
enact tplf transparency laws to protect
the fair and efficient administration of
justice this includes legislation that
requires Common Sense guard rails around
the use of tplf including funding
prohibitions so again if I can ask you
to turn a page number six in the law or
the bill as
written page number six lines 20 through
37 then on to page seven all the way
through 26 that's dealing with all those
guard rails that we're putting in for
Consumer
Protection okay you can go over those
afterwards and then the mandatory
disclosure of the tplf Agreements are on
page number nine so if you want to take
a quick look at page number nine just
point those out to you real quickly as
well that's on lines 10 through 17
there's only three reporting
requirements it's not an exorbitant
thing that we're asking to be done here
okay discoverability of these
arrangements and lawsuits and state
level regulation of funders is the main
purpose of this bill by requiring
disclosure of tplf to parties in
litigation and the courts balance can be
restored to legal system and the related
increased product service and insurance
costs associated with us will be reduced
that's my testimony now I have two
things that we need to do a little house
cleaning on this uh turning Scher
brought it up to my
attention so we need to add a word
knowingly at the very end and we left
out a section that we had originally in
there I sent you this one page I gave it
all to you this one page this needs to
be incorporated bill at a later date but
he understands that where we are going
to put it into the
bill and with that I'll take any
questions if you have
any okay representa spear
thank you so getting to the what we were
talking about I know what the CFR 791 is
and I know the countries that are in it
and they're kind of like known
around but I looked at the Constitution
and I can't find any place in the
Constitution that says the governor has
the right to declare another
country to be a threat to our
infrastructure so where where are we
getting that
from I don't know it's another country I
think it's more of an entity or an
entity from another country although one
here is says
country or a country designated as a
threat to critical infrastructure and
what criteria would they use and where
did they get the right to do that and
it's not in the New Hampshire
Constitution that they have the right to
do that so I would like you to look at
that a little bit okay we can look at
that I'll have the lawyers look at that
too yeah so where is that uh page on the
new bill on the new uh amendments page
three around lines seven and eight
nine it's on page three lines 10 and
11 of a code of federal regulations or a
country designated as a threat to
critical infrastructure by the governor
by written notice of the Department of
Safety so I think it's the department of
safety that's making that determination
and passing
this is under definition this is under
definitions yeah but then it but
throughout the document it calls out a
person or country of concern and the
definition of a personal country of
concern is somebody designated by the
governor among other things okay so who
should who should be someone who decides
that it better than the Govern I have no
problem with CFR
791 but I don't think the governor has
any right to say or even knows who is a
threat what country is a threat to our
infrastructure
okay
gotcha yeah all
right so was that in the original en
coil legislation oh yes okay I'm sure
they have a good reason for that all
right any other questions you another
one different
one all right if now getting to the CFR
791 China is of course on that list mhm
I think it's something like 20% of our
lumber of our it's certainly our
hardwood lumber in upstate goes to
wholesalers and distributors in China
does this
mean your interpretation since you've
been with this a lot longer than I have
does this mean that we can default on a
delivery and they cannot Sue to get
their
delivery by contract for instance
supposing supposing uh some third party
in China wants to back up we we don't
deliver they paid for it we didn't
deliver yeah now there's a lawsuit
between these two people and they hire a
third
party to help fund that
lawsuit does that mean that they cannot
do that that third party would have to
report and if they're on this list no
they wouldn't be able to do that they
wouldn't be able to do it right so these
These are outside
entities influencing lawsuits right they
have no interest in the lawsuit other
than monetary
gain that's what this bill is aiming for
okay so the
Chinese receiver of the lumber still
could could sue to get their Lumber yeah
but they can't have a third party
financing it according to those well the
question would be is would they have
solvency issues or financial issues that
would need them to find a third party to
finance that's the question that's
that's the question and and so what
we're saying is if it's a foreign if
it's a foreign trans your no your B bets
off that the ability to do this
financing is is is really only American
citizens we only want we only want
Americans to be able to get this because
really it's more aimed at an actual
citizen not even for a small Corporation
corpor we assume corporations know what
they're doing and know how to how to
handle their litigation expenses would
you believe would you believe you
believe
okay any other
questions oh yes representative Sal so
sorry I'm uh not as prepared as I should
be because I didn't get this I didn't
get to read this before I came in but is
this essentially saying that if I were
to be in a lawsuit I couldn't get
funding or financing to help pay for the
expense of that lawsuit by somebody who
isn't party to the lawsuit that is not
saying this at all okay this is a
reporting measure oh it's purely about
reporting that's right we're not saying
that the activity cannot occur okay we
just want to know who's doing it and to
what extent okay so if I found some
outside investor who thought oh I'm
going to get a share of your your
windfall if you win um I can do that and
then that that but that has has to be
disclosed that this company is okay
correct and isn't it true that some
states actually did try to C that
contract and how much you could get but
that is not in this Bill yes that was a
consideration sure it's a Live Free or
Die
[Laughter]
yeah okay thank you very much thank you
all right uh
Brandon because I know you're a busy man
so I want to have you come up right away
and and let us know what your concerns
are
g
g good morning good morning Mr
chairperson members of the committee my
name is Brandon grat I'm a senior
Assistant Attorney General and chief of
the consumer protection and anti trust
Bureau at the New Hampshire Department
of Justice here neither in support nor
against this bill nor with any opinion
on whether it's needed or the merits but
simply to point out that I believe the
enforcement Provisions that have been
built into this which anticipate
attorney general enforcement um perhaps
are not not as well thought out as they
should be and don't actually provide
meaningful opportunity for the Attorney
General's office to be able to prevent
to enforce and hold accountable those
who might violate this I
currently if I'm reading it
correctly there is an enforcement
provision for the Attorney General's
office that is built in um looks like on
page
8 um 294 f7b
a consumer litigating funding company
that violates any provision of this
chapter in a specific funding case b
shall be liable for a civil penalty of
not more than the fines established in
RSA 358
C4 for each violation which shall acre
to the state and may be recovered in a
legal claim brought by the Attorney
General so that gives us the ability to
pursue a civil penalty um and to do
nothing else so ordinarily we would have
all the rights and remedies available
under the the consumer protection act uh
including the ability to go to court to
enjoying the conduct and protect people
from further harm this simply gives us
the ability to pursue a penalty and if
what we're talking about is a $400
billion operation as was described by
the sponsor I I would suggest that a
$10,000 penalty is probably going to be
written into the cost of doing business
and won't pose much of a real threat to
anybody who wants to completely ignore
this and challenge the Attorney
General's office to come get him with a
fine um happy to Force this bill if it
was put into law however I think that
you know anytime the Attorney General's
office is given an enforcement
responsibility it's important to give us
broad authority to take measures that
are appropriate to not only f a business
but to prevent the conduct from harming
anybody in the future if they're
ignoring state law and I think that the
way this is written we may not have that
opportunity so I wanted to be sure to
point that out and to posee for your
consideration that you know if the
Attorney General is going to be
enforcing this and holding companies
accountable to the requirements that are
biged into this bill um we should have
all the rights and remedies available
under 358a in order to enjoin that
conduct seek restitution investigate not
just merely the ability to bring a claim
for a civil penalty well not
withstanding that we're talking about uh
could potentially Assurance
product and insurance is technically
exempt for the consumer protection act
so wouldn't we have to then cover that
shortcoming also potentially um I I I
know that there are a number of folks
here from the insurance department who I
think could speak to whether this is or
is not an insurance product and in what
context it would or wouldn't be um I
admittedly know where that line is
sometimes but not all the time so all I
can speak to is there is built into this
a expectation that the Attorney
General's office will be able to to get
civil penalties there could be an
exemption issue in there as well but
even if there isn't I I don't think that
this is going to provide the AG's office
with the meaningful opportunity to do
anything about violations of the statute
so how about we just lift the penalty
not make any reference to 358a but just
lift the penalty of triple
damages which is a right of private
private right of action and just leave
it as a private right of action rather
than getting the AG's office involved at
all that is certainly up to this
committee if if that's the the TR that
you want to take um I would leave it to
my colleagues at the insurance
department to speak to whether they
would have any meaningful enforcement
over this um certainly if what you're
trying to regulate is a business that is
using a product that is ripe for
Consumer Protection violations which it
seems that this would be I would imagine
you would want at least one state agency
with the ability to meaningfully enforce
it so I can't speak to whether the
insurance department would be able to do
that um as it's worded I don't think the
Attorney General's office would be able
to do it right okay so we we just need
to move it out of the 358a and put it
into the consumer protection statutes in
the insurance department if the
insurance department wants it
well there's the question of want and
there's also the question of whether
it's appropriate always would be an
insurance product over which they would
have the authority um certainly if it is
then they would if it isn't then we
would if it's an unfair deceptive actor
practice which currently it isn't it
just gives us the ability to seek a
civil penalty so I think all of those
considerations are the points that I
wanted the committee to take away from
my testimony happy to answer any
questions if I can be helpful perfect
thank you thank you very
much okay call up uh DJ Benton Court
from the New Hampshire insurance
department good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
DJ beton Court commissioner of the New
Hampshire insurance department you guys
have put my law school education to the
test here this morning thinking through
some of these
issues I'll focus on the insurance
pieces
first but I have nothing to say on
international law so I'll disclose that
at the
outset uh what brings the department
here today and I've talked to you about
this on a number of occasions already
and I won't get into it but we've talked
about the current hard Market that the
industry is going through and I think as
I've mentioned before some of the
industries that are most in impacted by
the current hard Market are
nonprofits and just recently has come on
to my radar daycare centers and Child
Care Centers they are really struggling
those nonprofits and those daycare child
care centers are having a very very
difficult time finding liability
insurance and where they can find it it
is enormously expensive because as I've
said there's a basic Supply demand type
Dynamic that sets in that the narrower
the access to coverage the more
expensive the coverage that remains
becomes and as you look at the
components of that hard market and again
I've talked about this before but social
inflation is one of the drivers of that
hard market and so we look at this
legislation as having the potential to
play a significant role in softening the
hard Insurance Market in a handful of
ways the first is with enhanced risk
transparency and so by disclosing
litigation data insurers gain clearer
insights into the risks associated with
specific sectors or types of coverage
this transparency helps them better
evaluate and price policies which can
potentially lead to more competitive
premiums the second is improved Market
competition when litigation data is
readily available it allows insurers to
identify areas of opportunity or
underpricing in the market this can lead
to increased competition amongst
insurers to offer better rates and
coverage options which again can
alleviate the pressures of a hard Market
third informed underwriting decisions
access to third-party litigation
information AIDS insurers in making past
litigation outcomes um excuse me access
to thirdparty litigation information
AIDS insurers in making more informed
underwriting Decisions by understanding
past litigation outcomes insurers can
adjust their risk assessments and policy
terms which can lead to more favorable
conditions for policy holders fourth
encouragement of innovation of
innovative solutions with a clear
piction picture of litigation Trends
insurers may be encouraged to develop
Innovative products or services that
address specific risks this creativity
can lead to more options for consumers
can help increase competition and help
stabilize the market Market fifth better
claims management transparency in
litigation can improve claims management
processes allowing insurers to identify
common issues that lead to disputes by
proactively addressing those issues
insurers can reduce claims cost and
enhance their overall profitability
which in turn can lead to more favorable
market conditions and lower premiums for
consumers so in in summary Mr chairman
the disclosure that is contemplated in
this legislation helps insurers meet the
regulatory requirements as well as the
other items that I've listed there and
the transparent the transparency can
help maintain the overall health of the
insurance Market by ensuring the
companies are accurately representing
their risk exposure the disclosure of
third-party litigation can enhance
transparency support better risk
assessment and management Foster
competition and ultimately lead to a
more efficient and stable Insurance
Market before I conclude I would just
note that we deal often times with model
legislation the model legislation that
we most commonly deal with are typically
model laws or rules that come from the
National Association of insurance
Commissioners we don't see as many from
En coil which stands for the National
Council of insurance legislators but my
experience has been that while there is
a lot of stakeholder input there's a lot
of vetting that goes into these model
laws and most of the time they take
years to develop to work through all of
those issues and to ensure that all of
the stakeholders have had an opportunity
to share their feedback you have to have
a certain level of flexibility within
the models to account for the various
nuances that each state is going to have
to account for so the fact that there
are some language considerations that
probably need to get worked out during
the subcommittee is hardly
surprise uh with respect to the issues
that the Attorney General's office
raised I'm a bit skeptical that we'll
have authority there uh this is a
financial type product and not one that
we would typically oversee so I'm not
sure that the entities identified in his
testimony are ones that we regulate but
we can certainly have a conversation
that pulls in not only the Attorney
General's office and my office but
probably banking as well to make sure
that we're getting that exactly correct
banking along with insurance has our own
ability to enforce the consumer
protection act that is outside of the
authority of the Attorney General's
office so that's why we'll need to bring
those three parties together to figure
out exactly as Mr Gard identified where
the lines of authority are so that we
can collectively make sure that we're
getting this legislation where it needs
to be so with that said Mr chairman I'm
happy to take any
questions um I guess I'm I forgot to ask
Brian did who's who's the reporting to
who who in the transparency of this
where they reporting it who are they
reporting what is it Secretary of
State's office yeah Secretary of State's
office okay um and then but at this
point um you don't see this as
technically you're being regulated by
you anyways it's not clear to me that we
would be the ones that so theoretically
because this is in would you believe
that this is this is really I guess
something that's going to be handled the
penalty but through a
litigation then the penalties really
should just be uh uh the triple damages
just the phrase the triple damages and
let the court uh handle the case
complaint the in cour and keep it out of
insurance and banking all together Mr
chairman if you believe it I believe it
that's certainly an
option well I'll see what I believe
after the hearing thank you very much
you bet you thank you Mr chairman now
let's see what I really believe Let's uh
let's have uh Marissa Chase and
Samantha heaving from the trial lawyers
who are in opposition to this
legislation just happened to not be in
the room and I said is there anybody in
opposition but I'm glad you're here so
we we do get the other point of view
which I love to have thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Marissa Chase I'm
the executive director for the New
Hampshire trial lawers Association the
plaintiffs bar and uh with me is
Samantha hering from um the law firm of
shaheena Gordon she's a member of our
board I just want to start out with uh
this is a na as we've heard this is a
national model piece of legislation I
believe it's well intended this is very
biased and one-sided this only seeks for
disclosure on the plaintiff side there
are no similar uh Financial disclosures
meant on or in this legislation
placed on the defense side if this were
really about transparency I think we
would ask the insurance companies to
disclose how much they're setting aside
in reserves to settle any single uh oh
we've heard that issue before we have Mr
chairman we've been through this dance
before and I will this is the opposite
side of the dance right no no I think
it's the same thing okay um but and
before um uh attorney hearing gets into
her testimony I will just note that you
know New Hampshire's is a small state
with a collegial bar this is our members
do not recommend generally for
plaintiffs to seek litigation funding um
we are not um you know we we don't
believe that they often we believe they
often do not serve the best interest of
claimants this again this is a small
state we're not a state that sees
massive torts or massive class class
action lawsuits this type of let um
advanced funding litigation typically
happens elsewhere in the country
thankfully not in New Hampshire we don't
have to um burden ourselves with that so
we believe this bill is unnecessary and
already uh any concerns that this seeks
to address are already covered by court
rules not by implementing a new statute
that um I was looking at RSA
294 um and this is kind to govern
disclosure in court proced procedure
this seems like a weird place to put it
so with that I will turn it over to
Samantha if that's
okay thank you and I would Echo what
Marissa said about our general policy I
shouldn't say policy our general rule of
thumb as attorneys who practice with the
tri trial lawyers group is that we
strongly encourage our clients not to
seek these contracts um you know I tell
people something to the effect of it is
your money and you know it's not my
place to tell you what to do with it but
I want you to be aware of these really
high interest rates and how over time
the amounts can build um that's
certainly something that a lawyer should
be counseling their clients about but I
don't I don't see that the disclosure
requirements of this bill in in terms of
disclosure to litigation parties not the
terms of what should be disclosed in a
contract to the consumer but the
disclosure Provisions in this bill
regarding disclosure to parties of
litigation don't do anything that I can
see to advance the claimant's interest
or protect the client in any way um New
Hampshire already has a sufficient
system system of mechanisms in our court
rules to make sure that parties are
giving the other side all relevant
information and Discovery you know we
start with rule 22 automatic disclosures
in every case where uh within 30 to 60
days of pleadings being filed at the
beginning of the case parties have to
give certain information to each side
list of people with relevant information
a copy of all documents that are
relevant a couple other things now of
course you don't have to trust that your
opposing attorney is going to give you
everything that's relevant you can still
seek Discovery under rule 21 from the
court and that rule sets out various
methods in part A I
believe um if I were to seek Discovery
from my opponent and they were to
improperly fail to respond or respond
with an objection that just truly has no
merit I can go to the court I can seek a
a motion for conditional default I can
also seek a a motion to compel to force
them to give me that information and in
that process what the judge does as many
of you probably know I'm sure is they
they appli the our our test to determine
whether evidence is
relevant
um under rule 401 evidence is relevant
only if it has a tendency to make any
fact of consequence in the action more
or less probable than without the
information fact of consequence is an
element of the claim or the defenses or
even damages um but it's certainly not
the existence of a funding
contract the other point that I would
make is regarding the privileged
Communications provision which is under
F10 excuse me 294
F9
um that makes the communications between
the consumer's attorney and the funding
comp company privileged only with
respect to the person against whom the
legal claim is asserted but it is not it
does not mirror the language of the
disclosure provision which says that
consumers have to provide that to
parties that they filed a claim against
parties to litigate or any insured with
an obligation to Ure the claim that's
being
litigated um so I think those
Communications should be privileged from
start to finish but I I just want to
Echo that in a system where we often
defer to judges and courts to determine
issues of relevance admissibility who
should get what documents in a case what
does the case actually need I think that
we should continue doing that sometimes
we lawyers like to fight for no reason
and the judges can resolve that very
quickly um
also I think transpar if transparency is
the goal I think we can establish that
very well for everybody involved by
having a judge do for example in camera
review of any relevant documents before
deciding whether that's disclosed to the
other party happy to take
questions okay any questions from the
committee members yes
representative if thank you for letting
me ask a question thank you for your
testimony do you happen to know
currently if there are any third party
litigation
financing um agreements currently in New
Hampshire with any cases yes I do I know
that it's come up in the context of the
YDC cases which I'm sure everybody here
knows about
um some attorneys who took over uh later
in the process once those cases had
already become they' already started
they were already maybe halfway through
or so attorneys took over later what we
realized was funding contracts were
already well established for those cas
bis and the train had pretty much left
the station so in that
circumstance we do have to sign the
contracts on occasion but that's the
only context I'm aware of that it's
actually come
up okay thank you very
much okay uh so
um Nat Grace from the Bia
thank you Mr chair n gra for the
business and industry Association
Statewide Chamber of Commerce we support
this legislation um I will be as brief
as possible um I think the five reasons
uh listed by commissioner bonc Court are
uh some of the main reasons that we
support this legislation so I'm not
going to repeat those um I I do want to
address uh one particular ular thing
here um this uh this issue was brought
to our attention by the US chamber as an
emerging issue um New Hampshire despite
being a small state has become you know
increasingly attractive as a place to uh
to see uh this type of funding um simply
because the industry as uh the sponsor
mentioned in his opening statement is
growing um so they're looking for new
markets we also have cases like YDC that
are attracting this type of invest
um and other states are enacting
transparency laws as well which is uh
encouraging the uh the market to adjust
and to move into States like ours that
don't yet have this type of transparency
legislation um because we don't have it
in place we really can't accurately
judge uh how how much of this is
occurring in the state um and we think
that this is really important for the
process uh that I outlined in my letter
which is really so that the parties
litigation and the court system
understand what's happening um they
understand the different dynamics that
are occurring and they can make uh
reason judgments uh within the context
of the case certainly happy to take any
questions anyone may have um and I'm
happy to work uh further with anyone uh
on the subcommittee on
this okay guess we don't have any
questions thank you
uh Cam and Lindsay from or
Reno we have camp we have C
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record I am cam leine
I work at or and Reno I here today
representing the American Property
Casualty Insurance Association and the
New Hampshire Association of domestic
insurance companies we are in support of
this bill I will be as brief as I can
the prime sponsor and those for me did
fantastic jobs um um presenting the
bill this practice of an uninterested
party coming into a lawsuit to provide
for solely financial reasons dates back
hundreds of years and it was illegal
under English common law for hundreds of
years under the practice called champery
and
maintenance it was not until the
1990s uh it's my understanding and I'm
not an attorney let me begin with that
um it's my understand in the 1990s in
Australia uh where the modern practice
of third party litigation financing
began and it has swollen to as the prime
sponsor testified a $400 billion Global
industry um this as others have said is
a very uh unclear unregulated shadowy
industry um the impetus for this bill
House Bill 733 came about uh over this
uh last summer in Fall there was a study
committee Senate Bill
236 um which I would the staff member of
that study committee before I entered
this role when I worked for the Senate
um and one of the things that that
committee it was a study committee about
the uh hard Insurance market for
nonprofits and one of the things that
came up in that committee was um uh
nuclear verdicts the incredibly high
costs that insurance has to pay and
nonprofits being pulled into lawsuits
that they have no there was no reason
for legitimate reason for them to be
brought in other than seeking another
pot of money to get um so that's where
this bill came from um I'm just checking
my notes here to make sure I didn't miss
anything I think that is everything I
want to add I'd be happy to take any
questions if there are
any R Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you
for your testimony um you you just
describe the sh the shadowy
industry and I'm just wondering how does
that work how do they uh how do they
determine which cases they they're going
to uh pursue to sort of reinforce so
that they can share in the rewards how
how does that uh work in your
understanding sure so my understanding
uh thank you for the question my
understanding is that they look these
well first off we don't know how often
or uh how many of these cases there are
because there is no disclosure
transparency unless you're in one of the
states that has
enacted uh or the Court District that
have enacted disclosure rules um Min are
saying is that they're just looking for
the biggest pot of money that they can
get um and and support those cases to
bring in um that
money brother set there we all set all
right thank
you Eric uh Schuler
POS of the bill as is okay there we go
you would like to see I qualified yes
qualified who is
Arc good morning Mr chairman my name is
Eric Schuler I'm the president for the
alliance for responsible Consumer Legal
funding it's easier just put Arc that's
kind of what we go by so say it again
the alliance for responsible Consumer
Legal funding where the trade
Association largest trade associ a that
represents the companies that offer the
Consumer Legal funding product uh first
of all I want to thank representative
Cole when this bill first came out um he
was very receptive to meeting with me
and with the other interested parties
and trying to work out a bill that I
think with the amendment we're uh pretty
much in agreement too um it's kind of
nice to see everybody on the same side
as opposed to everybody yelling at each
other across the table uh so I want to
thank him for uh allowing me to come in
and make some some suggestions to the
bill and which in the amendment is the
suggestions that we put forward uh to it
one things I think I just wanted to kind
of maybe take a half step backwards and
clarify there's two products that fall
under this the term of
tlf one of which is Consumer Legal
funding the other was litigation
financing and they're two different
animals but they get lumped in under one
umbrella so what litigation financing is
is it it is just that it finances the
litigation the money is used
specifically for attorney's fees Med uh
attorneys fees deposition costs uh
making sure the court filing fees are
covered all things like that Consumer
Legal funding is where a company gives a
consumer who has a pending legal claim
in most cases their car accidents so
money for immediate household needs
mortgage car payment things like that
and we're clear the funds we provide the
consumer cannot be used to fund the
litigation to give you some differences
our average funding on the consumer side
is about $3 to
$5,000 the minimums on the litigation
financing side start at $3
million it's just a couple of zeros
difference I gave testimony in another
state and one of the legislators told me
well it's a government rounding error
but that's another
story and what I really like what
representative Cole did was we clear
Define the two products in the the new
draft of the
legislation we recorded differently the
consumer side of things and I call the
commercial side of things so you're
regulating properly the Consumer Legal
funding the consumers who get money to
make sure they can keep a roof over
their head and food in the table and
also addressing directly the differences
on the litigation financing side of
those entities that give money to fund
the actual litigation
itself um
we when the the phrase came up you know
this is a $400 billion do a year
industry I want to clarify that's on the
litigation financing side that's not on
the Consumer Legal funding side trust me
if we're $400 billion do a year industry
I'd be asking for one heck of a
race we do do some work in New Hampshire
I I've did some some checking and I
think we probably do about 150 to 200
transactions a year so on the Consumer
Legal funding side it's not a huge
Market but I'd like to have 50 statutes
states I want to make sure that the
consumers who are getting the Consumer
Legal funding product are getting it
from responsible companies getting it
from companies that um are doing it the
right way it also actually helps my
companies because if you're doing work
especially in a financial services and
in an area that's unregulated you could
have one court order you could have one
decision come down and it could wipe out
your entire portfolio by having guard
rails on it you're ensuring that what
you're doing is doing it properly the
consumer is protected and the legal
system itself is also protected so with
that I'll happy to answer any
questions um are you regulated by
anybody in certain States we are yes
under Insurance well it depends upon the
state so in some states it's it's a
registration with secretary state's
office which I think is kind of looking
at here some states it's uh Department
of Consumer Credit other states a
department of banking it's a little it's
whatever that particular state has um in
Ohio as an example it's basically uh
Thou shalt and thou shalt not type of a
thing there isn't a registration or a
regulator there um if you're interested
you can go to our website which is on
the the portfolio on the right hand side
you can see all the statutes that have
passed across the country
okay so making sure this is what we call
a classic language issue yes it's key
word the words are it means everything
so um you're really financing you're
really a a a loan bank you're loaning
people money up front and and expect to
get paid back once the case settles well
we don't consider a loan because with a
loan there's a guaranteed some certain
of payment meaning that if I give you a
dollar today no matter what happens I'm
getting my dollar back and if I don't
get my dollar back I can do something
negative to you the only way we get paid
back on the contract is if the consumer
is successful in their claim and then
secondarily if there's enough funds left
over so after attorney's fees medical
leans statutory leans then we get paid
if there's not enough money to make that
obligation we don't get paid and also in
the rare occasion and it does happen
where the consumer drops the claim so
let's say they go to their attorney and
say hey where are we with this and the
attorney says well we've got a good case
but we're looking at another 12 18
months on this and it's like I'm tired
this snow I'm moving to Florida and
drops the case there's nothing we can do
we're just out that money the only way
we can go after a consumer is if there's
fraud involved and because we have the
attorney sign off the transaction the
attorney would have to be involved with
it and I really don't know many
attorneys who are willing to lose their
law license over $3,000 someone else
got so it's like mortgage insurance that
you're covering it's it's I mean if you
had to to Kin it to something is more of
a of a speculation for lack of a better
term it's we're saying yeah okay there's
a good probability you're going to be
successful in your case and if you're
successful we get paid but if you're
unsuccessful we don't and about 10% of
the time our compan get absolutely zero
back and about 30 to 35% of the time we
get less than contracted amount back so
it is a very high-risk
business okay representative
Kips thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming to testify this morning um
this bill uh deals with litigation
funding um and You' specified that
litigation funding and Consumer Legal
funding are totally different um does
this bill that's before us today deal
with Consumer Legal funding in any way
yeah and it does in the general form and
also specifically also in the the new
Amendment it it clearly defines better
we think the differences between the two
but it does regulate both the consumer
side and the commercial litigation
financing side it does regulate both
entities so you're in this language here
is what is what you want right that and
the and the the major Amendment yes
thank you
what do you mean by Major
Amendment this
is okay but this is the amendment that
you're talking about yes but in terms of
the regular bill but that adding this
paragraph right yeah I'm referring to
202-
03218 okay it was where we're in support
of oh I have 294 F5 and then F7 am I
missing another page something
here okay yeah all right representative
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony um just to help me better
understand your industry you have a
contract it goes to a potential client
or partner their attorney reads the
contract correct what's your
relationship with their attorney it's
basic are they part part of the contract
do they sign off and they just basically
acknowledge it because we want to make
sure that the attorney is fully involved
and fully knowledgeable of it because
it's actually the attorney who repays
the company out of the consumer's trust
account so when an basically an
insurance claim comes in and gets paid
it goes to the consumer's attorney goes
to their trust account and then the
attorney is the one who cuts the checks
they cut a check to themselves to any
other medical leans or whatever it is
and then they cut a check to us so we
want to make sure they're fully aware of
these transactions right from the GetGo
just quick followup for the question
meire so the the attorney doesn't have
any contractual relationship with you no
but they benefit by approving the
contract right so if they say yes you
know I advise you to sign this they're
getting a cut of the proceed the
potential
windfall well no they get their money
out of the the settlement not from us
and we're clear in the statute there can
be no quid proquo between the funny
companies and the attorneys so there's
nothing in going between us they only
get paid out of the settlement as well
all right thank you
so are you in this bill now in other
words is it it are you uh required under
this bill to report yes your transaction
correct so you're still you part of the
uh okay the yes the fair all right great
any other questions to committee members
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very
time okay uh Nathan fennessy from AIG
morning chairman members of the
committee uh Nathan fennessy I'm an
attorney at predy flarity here in
conquer I represent AIG when I don't
have uh when I'm not up here spending
time with you I I defend and and
litigate cases um so I want to speak to
really just the disclosure piece of this
which is why AIG supports this bill uh
for years in New Hampshire uh defendants
in in litigation have had to disclose
information about their potential
insurance policies that could apply
including policy limits uh what we're
looking for here is uh what I would say
reciprocal transparency which is if uh
if either a consumer or a business is
getting some funding for their
litigation that they simply disclose
that information so that everybody
understands who has a potential interest
in the litigation who has control over
the litigation um we think that's a
that's a fair thing to do for both sides
um with respect to you know there's a
lot in the bill I I won't speak to all
the various Provisions in the bill but
we do think there's some common sense uh
uh regulations within it such as making
sure that a contract's filled out before
the consumer actually signs it that that
to us just seems like common sense so
everybody understands what they're
getting into so um that's all I have
everybody else has uh I think covered
most of what you need thank you jog my
memory because I know this was last year
but the issue didn't come to Commerce so
we we did pass the statute where but no
I I didn't think it passed it failed so
you imply that it did pass that you have
the uh disclose the so under court rules
you have to so in L so I I do want to
address one point so under court rules
there is an obligation under the
mandatory disclosure obligations for
insurance companies to disclose
information
uh that is in the court rules it's rule
22 so that's if the judge deems it
appropriate nope no so what was the
purpose of the Court the bill we passed
last year last year's bill was trying to
force insurance companies before there
was any litigation to give information
over to plaintiff's attorneys that was
the intent of that
bill right that didn't that one fail it
did not it did not pass so I I did just
want to address that one issue because
what I think I heard from um from the
Trial Bar was well if you want this
information you can just ask for it well
I can tell you in other states when
people have asked for it they've opposed
that and taking the position that this
is confidential it's not relevant you're
not entitled to any of this information
it doesn't impact any claim or defense
and so that's why these other states
have have moved forward with some sort
of a disclosure uh statute because doing
it in the context of litigation leaves
it up to an individual basis for a judge
to determine whether or not this
information can be
shared got it all
right thank you very much thank you uh
Chris you want to say anything I think
uh Chris nickolopoulos uh representing
the National Association of mutual
insurance companies I've provided you
written testimony we support this bill
we're happy to work on uh any of the
Amendments I think re Spear's might be
right that that reference to Governor
may may actually supposed to be
president and president and and and
uh president Department of State these
are these are U people that have been uh
characterized as foreign actors so I
don't think I think it's right that
might be a typo but we're happy to work
on that uh I think this is as the
President of the United States is
supposed to weigh in no these are these
are folks that have already been um
adjudicated as foreign actors um ah
already been identified
as the it's a federal it's referencing a
Federal Regulation for uh foreign actors
that have already been uh listed
gotcha um but otherwise this is a great
bill I think ensuring that consumers
understand what they're filling out
before they enter the these Arrangements
um is important and the disclosure is
going to make uh the whole litigation
process better I don't need to say more
than that great thank
you Jim do you want
to represent Jim Hayden from State
Farm and we'll wrap it up for us I will
wrap it up in as quickly as humanly
possible um so members of the committee
you're not going to take 10 minutes uh I
will take no more than five and a half
so members of the committee Jim hadum uh
here on behalf of State Farm one of our
state's largest writer of homeowners and
auto insurance and I I'm here to testify
in support of HB
733 um and I understand there's an
amendment floating around and I'm happy
to work with the committee on that
amendment I think that um you know State
Farms support of this bill I is really
focuses on the fact that uh this
litigation financing is a big business
it's here to stay uh and it certainly
helps uh folks in New Hampshire um with
their litigation and their litigation
expenses um that hopefully ultimately
will promote Justice um the concern we
have is it comes at a high cost and we
think it's in everybody's interest to
make sure those high costs are front and
center for anybody who's considering
taking out litigation financing um the
high cost comes in the form of legal
fees uh excuse me Interest fees and
other charges that go into the lending
um and this bill would make sure that
those legal fees excuse me financing
fees uh and interest are front and
center so that when an attorney is
looking talking to their client about
taking out one of the some litigation
financing it's obvious to everybody what
the cost is going to be um and when it's
referenced that this business operates
in the shadows part of the Shadows of
the fact that we in New Hampshire don't
have a lot of experience with this uh
and we and attorneys aren't really well
equipped to uh inform their clients
about how much they might be able to get
from or how much an alternative premium
finan uh litigation financer might cost
so you know by Disclosure and getting
that information front and center it's
going to make it a whole lot easier for
the uh attorney who's advising their
client about litigation financing uh how
much it's going to cost them in the long
term um but it's also important that the
uh consumers and the PLS here understand
the cost of involving A thirdparty
lender in litigation um basically you're
introducing someone who has no interest
in Justice and is frankly looking to
make sure they get a return on their
investment right so they certainly want
to know what your case looks like they
want to know all of the details and they
want to basically put themselves in the
middle of a litigation decision and
discussion between an attorney and
client um and that is understandable but
a necessary part of their willingness to
lend against the potential settlement of
return um and that plays out in the
Inception of the case where it's
question of confidential information um
and and strategies but it's also uh
involved in potential settlements
because uh the lender is going to have
an opinion about how fast and how much a
settlement might be um and so you know
they're really bringing someone into a a
business relationship that is is really
going to have an important say in
that
um I think it's clear that um when you
take away the financial impact of
litigation and and sort of pass that
risk off to a third party uh it is
necessarily going to have an impact on
the willingness of plaintiffs and
lawyers to bring cases and there's a lot
of thought out there that say say this
will promote frivolous litigation and
prolonged lawsuits um and I think that's
hard for folks to
ignore um and you know I think when it
the discussion about uh secrecy and um
excuse me um about operating in the
shadows you know again Curr we don't
have a lot of litigation financing going
on in New Hampshire but it is going on
we don't know really who's doing it we
really don't know the terms they're
offering and but certainly by uh having
them register you're really asking them
to register to do business the way we
ask every other business to to you
basically put their name down and their
contact information with the secetary
state's office so that if someone has an
issue with this company um they know who
to talk to
um so with that um I would wouldn't
touch on one point that was made
about enforcement and um there's a
pretty powerful enforcement mechanism
built into the the bill and that is if
you violate the statute uh the contract
is null and void which basically means
the lender is not going to get their
money back so you have a really powerful
incentive for the responsible companies
that are willing to come to New
Hampshire and abide by our rules to you
know in effect you know abide by those
laws because the consequences of of not
abiding by our laws are simply they're
not going to ever get their money back
so um with that I would say I'm happy to
take any questions and I'm happy to work
with the subcommittee on any Amendment
repres
Amon thank you for allowing me to take
ask a question um I'm trying to
understand you know you represent State
Farm you you're probably involved in a
lot of litigation over auto accidents
I'm guessing or maybe even let's focus
on auto accidents what's your
relationship with these companies do
they do they uh bolster the client's
ability to um to litigate against your
claim sometimes or do they do you
partner with them in other times so that
uh you know you share the risk with that
company for you know whatever the
damages might be what's State Farms
relationship um typical relationship
with these types of companies
so State Farm does not itself have any
direct relationship with any of these
companies um and it very frequently sees
them on the other side of you know
involved in lawsuits that they're
involved in um when you think of where
this might come into play you know
there's um and I forget the terminology
there's lending in advance to a
plaintiff who you know is basically
looking to get their money faster if
when they have a lawsuit okay
um but there's also uh uh lenders who
will in effect Finance the the
litigation cost for uh for a whole sort
of broad range of lawsuits like auto
accidents in order to in effect Finance
the acts of the you know the the legal
representation of plaintiff's lawyers so
that's where it comes into play you know
more with relation to State Farm and and
lastly um we see a lot of this involved
in class action lawsuits um and and
there's plenty of examples out there
when for those big
cases okay so um are you suggesting then
when it came to the violation section uh
we don't need paragraph little B at all
just get rid of that and just stick with
the you you they lose their lose their
right to get any money out of the case
um so I don't have an opinion on that
right now but as I saw the committee
wrestling with the idea of enforcement I
think it's important to note that's
that's in there could be waved okay you
you're you're emphasizing a is already
there right but you're not necessarily
saying let's take B out but that that if
we did take B out that would certainly
clean up the problem yeah and I also saw
the commissioner and as well as so
here's this is a would what you believe
I'm sitting here
thinking that
if the um
if we're trying to settle a
case and the attorneys who you know were
who are defending are saying boy we want
to make an offer to the other side and
get them to take this offer and settle
the case so we don't have to go to court
or having the information about what the
liabilities that defendant has and all
the kind of thing contracts that they
have out there wouldn't that be helpful
in the sense that then you know you need
to make make an offer good enough so
that they still get something out of it
after they've taken care of all those
PLS would you believe that that might
actually be a useful way to settle a
case if both parties know if you the
other party knows what what they're in
for yeah Mr chairman um I would say I
not only believe it I've also been
through the discussions with the trial
lawyers about when they should have
access to certain information uh
relating to policy holders and I
understand the dynamic I understand the
tension and I'm certainly willing to
sort of uh discuss how to sort of just
balance that if if this committee wants
to go in that direction oh
balance oh I like
that thank you I'm here to
please well on that happy
note I will uh close the public hearing
that's
e
e e
okay let's uh everyone take their seats
and the peanut gallery
get their
seats okay so um this morning it's a
little lighter because we will not have
a 678 which is the uh over the counter
because that bill has officially been
withdrawn um and so we will not be
taking that up so we're really now down
to um 10 uh 949 499 making technical
corrections to certain insurance laws
and we've just had an amendment passed
out
everyone hopefully you have in front of
you it has my name and it's amendment
number
0364 and can I have someone from you oh
DJ you're here you want to just explain
what what we're doing here and
thank you Mr chairman joining me at the
table is Jennifer Smith our legislative
director so this amendment is seeking to
clean up a couple of housekeeping items
that came up following our signing off
on what I've nicknamed to be our
technical Bill my understanding is there
is Broad consensus around these changes
I don't believe there is any controversy
but we can certainly answer any
questions you have so in terms of what
was in the original Bill what's in this
amendment what why you know just give us
the highlights of the Chang so I think
the first part of it Mr chairman was
something that you had raised in terms
of in I'm sorry carriers the carriers
had raised it pardon me so I think the
statute originally said 800,000 so just
to back up for a
second now I'm all confused hold on a
minute right so we clarified that this
is only applying to new companies coming
in again the problem we were trying to
solve was the sometimes flood of
interest to form and domesticate a new
insurance company in new nights thought
it was number the low number was was too
appealing to ex choose New Hampshire to
create this scandalous entity and so our
team was just having to kick those
things back left and right so we wanted
to raise the threshold to get people who
are a little bit more serious about
actually doing good insurance work in
the state of New Hampshire so that is
where the uh language that you see here
comes from the number that we originally
set as I said to you I wanted to make
sure that we had a number that was not
serving as a deterrent to new players
that wanted to enter the market so we
picked a number that our team thought
met that criteria so this is this
company is going to be a domestic that's
right right so we don't want it to be
too high because we don't want people to
be scared in the hand we want to be
attractive so with three 3 million is
that are we still competitive I mean
absolutely any date out there there's
any lower than us are we like no that's
in line with Mo most other states Mr
chairman okay good all right so that
one's that one that's Jen you want to
hit the next one sure um so the next um
from line for lines 23 um that section
so 23 through 27 those two changes are
relative to the um producers fee ction
that's in the technical Bill those were
just some cleanup items that didn't
carry over when we were um making that
first amendment so that's just a couple
cleanup things um on those two pieces
there okay so we're adding this
$25 is it if it's amending that we're
now adding e we're adding the $25 yeah
and it has always been a $25 fee I just
didn't carry over into the billly oh so
it got deleted or the fee got deleted it
wasn't carried over PR
okay all right good we are still
preserving the elimination of another a
number of all the other ones right right
I know there was a cast you know a lot
of them and I would note Mr chairman
that I found myself in a very awkward
place of being a bit ahead of my time in
the sense that we identified those fees
as being inefficient and not a good use
of Staff time and an annoyance the
industry I'm sure the governor will be
very pleased with you I was just going
to say the governor the governor put
that foresight y the put C forward and
this was uh Roman Roman numeral one on
my memo about what we're going to do to
help with that cause perfect go ahead
okay uh and then the next Amendment on
page um the next change excuse me on
page one line 31 um in the original um
text of the bill that we put forward um
it was addressing our Network ATAC
reporting requirement in the original uh
original version of the bill we had
struck that requirement completely but
we wanted um to amend it so that um it
was known that this information was
still available and could be publicly
available to everybody um so we just
amended it so instead of getting it
getting rid of it outright just making
it more of a notification it's available
folks want it perfect Mr chairman if I
might well I have you all this is going
to be something that you'll see a lot
more of I suspect next year again as
part of the Cod process we've gone
through and analyzed all of the areas
within the insurance statute where we
have some some sort of reporting
requirement we're trying to determine
whether or not they're still necessary
and by necessary I mean are they just
checking a box that they're in
compliance rather than if we learn that
a company is not in compliance via our
consumer division or our enforcement
Division I can then request them to
produce the document that tells me where
they're at rather than having all sorts
of reporting requirements that are a
burden to Industry and often times do
not get the appropriate level followup
from the Department because we're just
buried in them so we're going to be
going through all of those over the
course of this year and coming back to
you probably with a number of these
again to try to not only be efficient
for industry and not a cost burden to
industry but also ensuring that we are
making the best use of our staff's time
right so it's a reasonable way to make
sure we have networ Network adequacy
without making a lot of in that
particular case that's exactly right
okay and we are in the process of our
updating our Network adequacy rules
right now at the department so that's
where this came up from where those are
ready to be filed with jail car well I
know the mental health was yeah mission
number one yes so um so more might come
that way from the network ad see as that
rule Works forward great um so the next
section come um so on page two line five
um this is relative to the law that
passed last year um SP 173 the no
surprises law um so these these are just
changes to um small changes to the law
we again over the summer after the bill
was signed and put into law we started
our rul making process on that bill um
and as we were writing our rules and
drafting those um it became clear that
we needed these small tweaks to the
statute to really um represent what the
were're trying to do in the bill
itself do you have to go back to Ru
making or did you actually already we're
in the process of it right now rules are
written and being filed which right we
just like tick of the egg which comes
first exactly so put simply Mr chairman
as you know the intent of the bill last
year as it pertained to balance billing
and those surprises Act was to mirror
the federal law we missed a couple of
Provisions there to make it mirror
exactly as we intended so we we fixed
that there
great so when we moveed forward again I
think it was last year with the enhanced
protections around consumer guarantee
contracts we scooped in um manufacturer
service contracts on the manufacturer
products that had not been included in
that before it was included in one
section but not the other we've
determined that they should not be under
that so we're just cleaning up that
provision that makes it clear they're
going back to how the regulatory
environment was for them prior to the
big uh enhancement Bill last year so
again that's a technical correction well
so who is responsible for those service
contracts Keith Keith yes who's
responsible for the manufacturing
warranty
stuff they're still subject to the
unfair Trade Practices statute I could
tell you that so there's not
complete you know free reign there we
still have some oversight there right
because but that's we get a lot of
complaints right to people who buy these
extended warranties and say so th this
applies to what we're talking about our
manufacturer service contracts we do not
get a lot of complains about
manfacturers contract service contracts
to who's buying these manufactured who's
who's I'm sorry Mr chairman so let's
take John Deere we had complaints about
John Deere so John Deere has a service
contract with a third
party or this is their there's this is
their their service contract on their
products and who's taking advantage of
this so under that scenario that would
fall under the Attorney General's office
that would be under consumer protection
anyways them okay so what yeah so give
me that's right give me one that I know
that we're is is that we're basically
taking things that normally would have
been a under the consumer protection act
and taking it out of your statute that's
right well this is a bit of a cleanup to
Mr chairman if you'll notice the
numbering is quite off when we issued
our bulletin over the summer um it came
to our attention so it went one two
three four nine so everything else had
been cleaned up and then that kind of
did not get cleaned up and when the bill
was in enrolling so it should be in the
next public utilities on no Public
Utilities okay and we did run this by
industry is the one that brought this to
us as well as when the bulletin went out
um so we addressed it with industry and
cleaned it up as they requested that's
right attorney Hayden back there is very
involved with those particular kinds of
products if you've got questions about
how they work or how historically those
products have been overseen I think
Jim's your guy you can you can get him
an extra hour he can Bill his client but
he had cell phones you know their
insurance products on cell phones I mean
you wouldn't believe you wouldn't
believe the number of times he turns up
on something you're like you're involved
with this too okay all
right I think that's it that's about it
that's just ruming okay all right any
questions to the committee members
too many hearings today Mr chairman
sorry that was a little
choppy no this no this this is a we're
in subcommittee so there's no
testifying okay thank you very much
thank you very much uh are are we ready
to take
action now we need
yeah okay so we
need so this is $499
you know I'm not really crazy about this
pre-
numbering but I guess it's good good to
make sure we don't forget somebody in
the way proc assess okay so it's not
executive though this is no this is the
subcommittee yeah cuz
you're but I thought that was what these
were just think by the time we get to
the Senate bills you'll have this down
to a
science don't even have
it this one let's use this one okay got
with oh okay so let's just use
that what's that cleaning
up9 and we're putting the amendment okay
so this what we're doing right here
is no this the executive session we're
doing doing that okay we just scratch
that all out
and and it's the uh technical the title
was technical corrections to insurance
laws okay and then we have the insurance
department U review of the amendment
then we Circle who's here on insurance
so who's who's insurance we got
prelli
Gibbs
miles
Cole sharesa
Spear and Hunt so the only one missing
is Burrows is burrow okay all right so
uh representative
hunt second by representative
spear moves ought to pass on amendment
number
364 that
otpa is otpa on the amendment on to pass
on the amendment okay
do the amendment we do the amendment
first all right any discussion on a to
pass on the
amendment seeing none all those in favor
please raise your hand one two three
four five six seven oh or oppos
representative Teresa Are You
voting you evidently are on the
insurance subcommittee right okay are
you voting for the amendment yes okay s
7 Zer okay uh now representative
hunt second by representative
spear moves add to pass as amended okay
so so now you're done with the next one
y it's very
confusing all right you'll have to find
out whether they're doing this right
we're doing this right or not okay all
right the motion is not to pass as
amended is there any discussion on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
please say I I 3 four five
okay and then adopted all right and
you're done okay 499 is done and on to
executing all right next up is 552
relative to coverage of children under
State retirees insurance plan
552 I believe we had no problems with
this bill right no cost to the state
right yeah actually I I have a question
on that okay sure the subcommittee so I
can ask question internally right in in
sub committees this is very relaxed
where it's a it's a conversation yeah so
the question is that uh you know it's
good that you don't require them to be a
student under 25 but right but I also
read that this is going to there's no
calculable impact on the uh financial
burden based if you include everything
right have we done a study how much and
who is going to take care of the
additional that this
bill um yeah this is under their entire
retiree plan so there there is no fiscal
impact to the
state because that that we we as long as
we fully fund our retirement plan you
know as long as the you know the
retirement plan is fully funded it's so
so what happened is in this case and and
and when we talk about the some of these
health insurance mandates that we passed
in the committee how it only affects a
small group of people or only expects
the small businesses and the individuals
and their insurance companies you know
will don't have to uh ra you know they
raise the premium to make up for that
mandate but when we passed that years
ago go I this
is I mean this was even before the
Affordable Care Act we had passed it
okay that um
obviously uh there were some people who
weren't
included
and that was the state
employees then what we now became
obvious was well not just the state
employees but what happens if the state
employee has
retired and they're getting their
benefits you know from the this
retirement
fund they shouldn't they their kids get
you know still have the benefit they
shouldn't lose it just because they
they're they retired and so that's why
it's a it's a minimal cost because we're
talking very very few people involved I
think it was only like 26 or something
so right
parent right has to pay not out of oh
they're actually oh okay I missed that
part I forgot about that okay I don't
have it in front of nobody's
here okay representative miles wasn't
the other aspect that they covered
without being
student well that was the that's the key
element of the 26 year old right because
in the way back when when we first
addressed the this issue and this was
before like I say it's before Affordable
Care Act so we passed this a long time I
would say I was not in the chair at the
time this was when I was on my
sabatical and um the the issue was that
we always required that you had to be a
full-time
student to be able to get the benefit
and is good it's uh just fairness you
know it's it's a fairness issue that
that everyone else is getting the
benefit because under the Affordable
Care Act it was mandated so it just the
nature of their insurance product is
being under this retirement plan it just
never got picked up and never got
allowable
in that's correct that's been that's
been like 20 years
now exactly that's that's under under
the Affordable Care Act that is how it
is it eventually well the Affordable
Care Act certainly picked up more people
it got the Affordable Care Act got the
orisas okay but that uh again that never
uh this this retirement plan is a very
unique product that was exempt from all
regulations so it never got picked up oh
so so so as of now the retirement plan
basically if they're not students they
will not be covered so they no if
they're a student it doesn't matter
whether they're student or not they can
get the coverage until they're
26 and that makes it the same for
everybody else in the country that's
what this one this B this build does yes
so so as of now it's not happening it
right at the moment it is not happening
that's that's why we need to pass this
bill that's why we want to vote ought to
pass so they can get the
benefit chairman you got it because I
know you got confused that last time so
yeah I I I got that part the only thing
is that I I'm still not clear is that
the retirement benefit plan that we're
talking about this is the employer the
employer is the state so they are the
one funding it it's not
got left out last time they got left out
but it turns out you're saying is it
still has money it's still the bill way
it read it says in the fiscal note it
says however the cost of a dependent's
coverage on the retiree plan is
$1,044 per month for a non medicare
eligible dependent paid entirely by the
retiree to the plan right yeah and and
the next long as you want to pay $1,000
a month you can get the benefit right
they get the coverage okay and the next
line also I had question that why it
says expanding eligibility may increase
enrollment and potentially increasing
cost to the retirement benefit health
benefit
plan you read you're reading the fiscal
note now yeah the the next line say the
fiscal
note I know what is he he's asking
something about that last phrase well
the the line that you read just now next
line it say expanding eligability may
increase enrollment and claims
potentially increasing cost for
the potentially inre for the retiree the
plan the retiree because the retiree has
to pay for the insurance plan for their
kid okay okay so as long okay so
basically there's no there's no
obligation of burden to the to the after
hearing this I would say no one's going
to take advantage of this because they
can get health insurance cheaper for
their
kid okay under the marketplace they
could just sign them up individually as
an individual and they wouldn't have to
do it so this is Feelgood
legislation because well I me say this
is an opport Unity for somebody who
might want to have have their kids on
the
plan kids are really cheap younger it's
oh well we had the way the the way
there's an age
ban okay and the age ban is 4 to one
so uh right now I would you know in
terms of my employee who was really up
there so it's like $1,500 a person so
divide that by four now you're down to
Ken talk
M oh
really okay so so for basically if I'm
if my understanding correct uh including
this is not going to increase the burden
on the insurance company or to anybody
else except the person who is enrolled
in that and they're going to bear the
cost Bingo you got it well then no
brainer then yes answer absolutely give
her
explaining okay uh is somebody else did
I did I did I sponsor this bill or who
did somebody else sponsor this bill
who's the
sponsor okay who anybody would like to
rate the blur on this one when we take
it up
so okay so can I ask you one quick
curious question if this was this much
uh you know uh easy and uh you know
no-brainer the why this was not even
brought up for last 15 20 years it was
just
neglected CU life is like
that um I have I guess I have to play
the tape and see what the the sponsor
said and how all of a sudden this she
they became attention did anybody
remember the hearing you take good notes
Sean what did she say in the
hearing there wasn't much on this one
there was no discussion L know is the
only one spoke
to the state only so the sponsor wasn't
even here right okay I
guess just not to ask why they forgot
about it okay so long oh it's Leno was
here yeah he was here he was going on
and on about how great a chairman I am
[Laughter]
and all I
remember he was thr Praises towards me
right and of course Senator rean is also
a former member of the committee so she
was she was probably on the committee
back when we passed it way back when
okay all
right right so represent Spirit you want
you'll make this motion for me sure okay
representative spear second by
representative hunt moves on to pass as
amended any discussion on the motion
seeing none wait a minute what amendment
no Amendment okay not to pass
to
pass no spear
spear me I'm not on the
committee I'm just a hang
okay uh all right um so uh the motion is
clear all those in favor please say I I
1 2 3 four five six seven seven zip and
on to exact
all
right 678 has been withdrawn so we're
done for this morning so this afternoon
all we have is the ambulances yeah all
three of them
that's that's a
big so the room will be a little busier
we take up
ambulances John we're not doing 678 as I
said this bill has been withdrawn I did
not hear that
you saw you came help me with a
pen you needed
help okay all right sub this afternoon
so the only yeah the only the
subcommittee is is the ambulance bills
so that's
it okay so then and I I have done
beginning my paperwork on for the next
two two week or three weeks let's call
it that uh so next week um I'm assuming
that uh at this point we have not been
able to get a smaller room so we will
have
subcommittees um in uh down in
and I tell you what I what I am
thinking
um I here okay no not it okay here we go
um
uh yeah I thought on sucess 78 the last
thing we had is she's going to come back
in with an amendment I guess nothing no
she then without without discussing it
with me or anybody she just ran down to
the clerk's office and and took out had
to have it withdrawn okay um well and
you know to be honest
is I I explained to her the difficult
the problematic issue is the
enforcement and they lift the statute
from I guess New York or and they were
Massachusetts but other states they the
Attorney General's Office of the States
you District Attorneys they they're the
ones who handle the consumer protection
laws okay and and so they contributed a
consumer protection issue so and I said
well how where's the enforce Mobility
who's who's making sure that that's not
getting sold oh no it's the same as we
always say the drop a dime you need you
know the only time they would worry
about it if somebody called up and said
oh by the way yeah you know you know
that that that the health food store was
selling selling that so once I explained
to her that in the Hampshire we don't do
it that way and that theoretically she
she would need to have the liquor we
need to put it under the Liquor Division
and because they're the only ones that
are in the out there checking for Aid
you know for selling to it and and and I
said that but but boy is that going to
be awkward yeah and um but it is not so
bad in given that pretty much you know
every
drugstore and grocer and uh convenience
stores because he was talking about
convenience stores all of them um sell
beer and so therefore the Liquor
Commission is already there is already
doing the already doing the agent
enforcement so the only people you're
going to that that's going to be
problematic uh is say let's say someone
did a popup thing in the in the mall
well we've done that too with the Liquor
Commission because they do The Vaping
you know there's those PP up vaping
stations
uh so I said that's not so bad so it's
it's not totally it was just it would be
it would just be a little awkward for
you know and but the other problem that
was wrong with the bill that I felt also
not that it makes any difference at this
point is that it was very broad some of
the things that were listed there were
legitimate vitamins and minerals and
things like that that you know I and I
said to her I said so let me get this
straight so the FDA doesn't regulate any
of these things that you want be worried
about whether they're over 18 by how the
heck are we going to you know
rationalize that enforcement I I
couldn't see
it
exactly so um instead of us killing it
she was afraid that that means she
couldn't bring it back next year so by
withdrawing it she can come back with
something could we have oh well what
that's what I told her I do I said I
said I said to her that out of on you
know we would you know this but she
didn't want to our reputation I don't
know how you do it on other committees
but in our committee is is we understand
that you're in a pickle and that this is
you know you're going to do a lot of you
know have to figure out how you how do
you want to do this and how how you're
going to spin it that you know you can
retain it and we'll take it up in
September and see what you got the
amendment that you got do that she she
had already already had gone to house
clerk to have it withdrawn and okay of
course my ation with TR is this is this
something we voted for you oh yeah yeah
we've all voted for this go I don't know
some but but it's you know obviously for
me it's a know we' you know we've never
had this withdrawal process but to me
the once a bill has been introduced and
certainly after we've had the hearing
that bill belongs to this committee it
doesn't belong to the sponsor but we
didn't have the hearing we did have the
here no we didn't we did no the first
thing she said she was here and the
first thing she said I want to withdraw
this bill that was the only thing that
was ever said that's a different bill
but no no it was this bill it was this
bill and she said she wanted to withdraw
it that's and that was all that was said
no no I'm saying it was Nome we had Nome
in Leno say please Nome and Leno were
the ones who came in and spoke for it
that's it I have it on my video I typed
it up last night really if she's
withdrawing it it doesn't matter all
that much when she withdrew it yeah that
is absolutely true represent again okay
so um I was just saying so terms of
next Tuesday next
week
um uh so I think in the morning in the
morning I'll be doing the business plans
business
bills and that the insurance
subcommittee we're this won't meet again
until um March 4th the subcommittee
sub committee
forance
okay
WN Wednesday is we have the whole
committee room so I want to I I you know
technically we're not supposed to be
allowed to go on vacation unless we have
you know got our business caught up and
so I was planning on um on on Wednesday
the 19th to hear the remaining eight
bills that we have and get get it done
so that means when we go on vacation you
know the on on speaking beginning the
21st we will have uh uh heard all our
bills and had subcommittees at least one
subcommittee on all the bills that need
to be done exact on and this is the
important date for everybody Wednesday
the
5th because Wednesday the 5th is our
exact session for the 13 bills that we
have have to be out on the six
okay so but I did schedule for Tuesday
the 4th again because we have a smaller
committee room the March 4th that
Tuesday 4th is is the uh health
insurance uh bills that are um have to
be out have to be voted on by the
5th now just to be you know honest Frank
if we get into that fourth and things
are not going well I mean in terms of
the glucose spill for instance if we're
not if we're not going to be happy with
what we're doing um uh you know if
anything if we have any the opiates you
know whether you know the sponsor I got
an email he's when I I send him the
amendment and he says he wants to talk
to me about it because he doesn't know
where what we're doing Le though we
can't read the bill or something I don't
know but he wants to talk about it so if
any of these bills go south on on the
fourth that we can't agree to something
well yeah on the fifth we'll just retain
it so why why did want
to yes what is it that we're doing on
the
18th on the that's what my question 18th
is going to be a subcommittee and that
subcommittee will be um liquor and
business bills thank you I'll be in the
housing committee that day right so this
subcommittee this subcommittee insurance
will not meet until the
4th thank you the fourth is a Tuesday
and you do have housing on
Tuesday it is what it
is so I mean I I mean in terms of you
know I I don't know what what will they
be doing on that day do you know what
they're doing on that day are they doing
hearings or are they doing Zing or what
are they doing I'm not yeah okay so but
you have your Vice chair here and I know
you're on it and represent the three of
you so we could certainly
um you know in terms of uh the issues of
what those bills are we can we will
figure something out because it's just a
subcommittee so we can be Flex if you
guys are suddenly into an exec session
and that so let's say in the order of
priorities um you're executing if you
exec anything on the fourth that's the
higher priority so that we will
accommodate you not to be in Commerce
okay um but if you're um if you're just
doing a hearing then then you can come
on down
yeah that okay that's fine all right and
we'll know and you'll feel you know what
Happ I'll let you
yeah but otherwise Wednesday the 5th is
um a dday for all executing all 13 bills
that I have to we have to have out of
committee that's right
okay will you keep track of who's going
to be writing blurbs because I remember
that worked out well when you send out a
list of this person is writing I I will
that's what I'm doing now so that when
we when we uh so and because my my
intention is as usual that by we get to
the fifth we'll already know what we're
action we're going to take and I'll have
who's going to make the motion and who
needs to have the blur and they need to
get the blurb done that
day
because because the six is the is six is
the deadline but they scheduled a
session on the deadline
day please don't ask
me that's
just my mission is not to ask why to do
and
die all
right we have a session on Thursday next
week
for